[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is a number one
best-selling author he's also the host
of the uh fastest growing podcast in the
ramsey network called the dr john
deloney show where people call in with
mental health questions relationship
questions we'll take those today as we
always do and we'll also take questions
about your job your career and oh even
your money andrew is going to start off
this hour in milwaukee hey andrew what's
up
hi dave thank you for uh taking my call
pleasure speaking with you you too sir
how can we help
so my question is
i'm in the middle of my baby step two
i'm hitting it with gazelle intensity
however i'm also
about one and a half years into my
relationship both of us are
we know we want to get married it's
going to happen this year my question is
essentially how much should i be
budgeting for the engagement ring and
when do i buy the ring is it my next
paycheck all that goes to the ring or is
that a sinking fund sometime within this
year the question about how much to
budget
i'm basically asking because i know you
typically say one month pay
my
one month pay is very different compared
to base compared to what i'm making
right now in gazelle intensity um
getting all the overtime that i am
getting
okay well congratulations how old are
you
i just turned 26 two days ago
awesomeness man well this is fun what a
great time for you okay so your range
of one month's pay plus base plus hustle
is what
what's the bottom end of this idea and
the top end of this idea
so yearly growth
base is 80. okay
right now gazelle intensity i'm taking
home 3 500 every two weeks paycheck
okay all right all right so 80 to 120
okay correct and so um what does she
make
she currently um is between 40 to 50.
what's she doing she's in between jobs
but that's
she was a director for a music program
now she's looking to transition to
potentially hr so she'll either one of
you grow up wealthy
uh no okay all right
well because there's a whole pl there's
a whole thing a whole lot of things that
go into this um the idea of one month is
to give folks a guideline because the
jewelry store the retail jewelry store
people will tell you three months but
that's a crock you don't need to spend
that much
um
number two you know what i was trying to
ascertain is expectations based on her
income how she was brought up
those kinds of things
and so and there's all these stories and
everything about rings and everything
else it's a fun time you're in for sure
and i want you guys to have fun with the
whole process and so we don't want the
ring to be
the center of the attention because you
went nuts on one side and we don't want
it to be the center of the attention
because you didn't spend enough on it
either on the other side right
so that's that's kind of the balance i'm
looking for just as an old grandpa here
um so if i'm in your shoes you know
probably the five thousand dollar range
is probably going to be fine that'll be
a buy pretty dadgum nice ring
i will tell you that diamonds having
bought quite a few of them over the
years
because the one i bought when i started
i had to upgrade a couple times since
but um
anyway the uh uh
they are completely worthless
and don't let anybody talk to you about
an investment the investment aspect of
them is a freaking joke the only
investment is into your relationship
and how she feels
okay
but uh i've got i don't know i don't
even want to say how much tied up in
diamonds and i have no expectation that
they're going up in value
because they generally don't it's just a
croc okay so don't get all caught up in
that the second thing about diamonds you
need to know is they're marked up
as much as anything we buy
furniture and diamonds double
they're double
okay so when you walk into the mall
jewelry store it's double what you can
get it from a diamond broker for
and so start doing some research and
learning because you can get
double for bang bang for your buck and
you need to learn a little bit about the
purchase process
uh the carrot the cut the clarity uh
those kinds of things and what makes a
good diamond but again don't get all
caught up in you know one flaw that the
naked eye can't see in the thing and so
it's a
it's a two instead of a one or whatever
and uh
because it's not going to matter
uh if anybody gets an eye down that
close to it they don't need to be able
to learn
it's fun to learn i i would just get
with uh somebody in your life that's
bought some in the past and or uh if you
can find a great diamond broker in your
area that will teach you a little bit
but don't get caught up in the uh and
shop around the last thing is if you
could really get somebody knows how to
put a glass on their eye the best place
to buy one's a pawn shop
because it'll be it'll be a third
of what you'll find in the retail and
you might but you might pick you might
buy a piece of glass too and not know
what you're buying if you don't get
somebody who knows how to put a glass on
their eye and look at it with you so i
would be scared to do that if i didn't
know the pawn shop owner huh
if i don't know anyone like that a
broker that's a pretty safe bet yeah but
just but again you got to go in there
like you do anything else where you're
doing an investment purchase and you
you're going in with finding somebody
with the heart of a teacher to teach you
about it okay okay and and the last
thing is this you're not going to mess
this up
because there's absolutely zero research
between the correlation the size of the
rock and the success of the marriage
but there is a lot of research on
husbands who uh
take a knee and they propose and then
they and followed up with
and i got this at a pawn shop
hey it depends on who you are and where
i got my poncho my wife would have been
so happy that's incredible but yeah yeah
other people wouldn't but here's the
thing there may be some inverse
relationship this as the rock is too big
the failing of the marriage is predicted
but because it seems to be we're
concentrating on the wrong things here
which is the relationship versus the
rock so does she talk to you about it
like what she's looking for
yeah i mean she she's given me her
expectations which are i mean she's
aware of how important it is for me to
get out of baby step two so she's giving
me yeah but i i don't option you take a
month off and go do this and do it right
but no it's not a ten thousand dollar
purchase in my mind and it's not a one
thousand dollar purchase
okay so pause baby step two to build up
five thousand dollars based on what i'm
making and then buy it resume baby step
two that's what there you go and here's
the thing i i know a lot of guys that
will have this conversation with the
person that they're going to get engaged
to
and then the person tells them hey this
is what i would love this is kind of
what the kind of band i would like and
the guy goes rogue because he thinks oh
actually i'm going to get and so man if
she's honorable enough to tell you
then listen listen man this is this is
test number one for many many tests to
come over the years just listen i'll
just tell you i don't buy them anymore
at all unless sharon does the design
she does my wife does not do surprises
is she not happy with the surprise
because i'm always wrong right so
i just
that's what she's she's not she loves
surprises she doesn't like it other
ladies like it they like that they like
the you put time and effort into it and
so forth but i've made that mistake a
couple times and i'll never do it again
so no we don't buy anything shiny
without sharing actually approving
being in on it so you could go that
route if you want to go really crazy
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
building wealth is a really hot topic
right now it's all over your social
media it's jamming up your email inbox
it's on the talk shows and podcasts the
late night news everyone's got an
opinion on how to get rich
quick and how crypto or single stocks or
zero down real estate
gold
whatever is the way to do it oh and
throw in inflation for a big dose of
fear on top of your fomo right so in
january we had a huge sold out event
here in nashville called wealth building
live
and we talked about how to build wealth
real wealth it was incredible the energy
in the room was amazing and it's so
awesome that we want to do it again so
we're hitting the road we're going to
get out there we're going to meet you
guys in person that's right the building
wealth live
event will be on tour in cities across
the country this year
the first city on our tour is orlando
so get ready orlando join me rachel cruz
george campbell when building wealth
live comes to you may 19th also john
deloney and ken coleman will be along
with us we'll be doing some stuff with
them as well tickets start at just 25 or
you can get a four pack for only 60
bucks that way you can sign up and bring
your friends that's a good idea that's a
deal come on guys i mean seriously be
sure to sign up for one of these uh one
night special events and we'll give you
the real story on the quickest
fastest most
sure way to build wealth ramsey
solutions.com events to buy tickets now
orlando is
on sale
now ready set go our question today
comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey and you'll have the best deal
today's question comes from james in
alabama james writes i'm in an
embarrassing situation i'm 36 years old
and i'm a hoarder
i have over fifty thousand dollars
invested into video games comics and
toys
this is consuming the home that my
mother and i live in which is making her
unhappy
i have about fifteen thousand dollars in
debt and earn about 35 grand a year i'm
really starting to wake up after
watching your show and i've been
thinking about selling 99 of my stuff
and living a simpler life
i just feel lost in the process and i
have trouble letting things go how can i
change my mindset about these things
i've collected
this tough
um
dave this is one of those challenges
that people start trying to solve the
the immediate pros the immediate problem
right in front of them
and you can do that but something that
is
going on in james life i'm gonna guess
is deep seated that he needs to go do
some hard work he's 36 still living at
home he's packed up stuff he's he's
running and hiding this is a person
who's very anxious
um and he's probably got some childhood
trauma that he's dealing with so when i
feel people get in this situation i just
can't break through i can't break i
can't break this person needs to go sit
down and she's awesome
is the symptom not the problem correct
right it is usually
um a response almost always is actually
some sort of anxiousness or trauma
response yeah i've had some stuff go on
and i just start collecting and
collecting and collecting and i don't
want to let go because i might need it
it's preparatory and all of a sudden you
look up and you can't move in your home
right
and this guy's distinguished for me
because i i've got this friend
who might be a little bit ocd and uh
he's got collections of things i have a
collection of water skis i have a
collection of
wine i have a collection of guns i have
a collection of whatever right
and um those things are things i got
drawn into
and usually the community around them
um and that they represent and or the
memory or something um and so i just
enjoyed the process and they and they
sometimes not all of them but some
things run their course like i i used to
buy a lot more guns than i buy now yeah
but i've kind of got the i'm kind of
full so i haven't bought in a bunch of i
don't buy
anywhere near the volume i used to uh so
i kind of ran its course so to speak but
that's a what's the difference in a
collector and a hoarder
uh i would suggest a collector or
somebody like you said that has a good
community this is something you do this
is something you enjoy
that thing that you're buying doesn't
own you right okay and so i get a
paycheck
i can't not go buy this thing okay it's
an addiction
and if i said if if sharon came to you
and said we have to sell some of these
guns your initial response is
i can't do that oh actually not an
intellectual argument not a not a well
why would we do that it's i can't part
with this and so you can look at
somebody's house who's a hoarder and say
throw it away
you're asking them to peel back layers
of security that they've walls that
they've built literally okay and so
this starts with man the fact that
there's even even a difference between
someone who's a very aggressive um
because i can remember like times i've
been in a zone like i i got on a hunt
for that thing yeah because to complete
the collection you're a hunter yeah
and i enjoyed that part of it but that's
different than i can't live without it
spiritually and you also did it
differently when you had resources and
finances and when you didn't oh yeah
yeah it's a very very small percentage
of the world
if you ever need to unload some of your
wine or guns or bourbon holler at me and
i know a guy but
so james here's the thing um i want you
to reach out to a friend reach out to a
pastor in your community that you trust
a counselor reach out to somebody and
say
i'm ready to get well and this is gonna
be hard and you're gonna have some stuff
you have to deal with you're gonna have
to go back and revisit some stuff that's
going on in your life but the fact that
you're ready is so good man that's hard
to get people here it feels like if you
if he were to come up under this
and start getting well the result would
be the release of it it can be that you
just started wouldn't be it wouldn't be
as much of a tearing right it feels like
right now there'd be a
ripping sound a tearing sound and when
that happens is what happens you'll find
somewhere else to plug this so you can
hire a crew to come clean your house out
throw everything away and that addiction
will just jump to something else yeah
right yeah the problem was still it's
still under there that's right somewhere
that's right but good for you james yeah
and you know here's the other thing i've
i've bought real estate from people that
were hoarders yes
and um
tremendous problem
uh
even getting inside to see the house on
the inside the shame yeah from our true
hoarder because someone is really
dealing with a psychological issue
the shame around it is unbelievable you
just called something that's important a
lot of people think i'm a hoarder
and then you go to somebody's home who's
a true hoarder and you go oh i'm not
trash it's completely i mean stuff
smells ceiling smells bad always smells
bad it's always nasty it's uh it's
animals it's different oh it's gross
it's different so gross yeah yeah i
bought houses like that and we had to
you know entire dumpsters outside after
the you know maybe even the hoarder had
passed away and we bought it from the
estate and gone in and cleaned it out
it's amazing and it's mind-blowing when
you go in there so anytime you're about
identity change it starts with looking
in the mirror and saying i'm worth more
than this and let's start the healing
there but good for you james i'm proud
of you brother yeah very good stuff very
good man yeah that's very smart to
recognize that and here's the other
thing he did really good that i think is
a sign for his healing is he put numbers
around this and he started recognizing
they were out of balance because he put
him in the email he did two things that
were i make 35 i got 50
and a
yeah i heard the three numbers and i
want to sell 99 of this stuff
yeah so he did two things he put numbers
around it and he took full
responsibility yeah he didn't say i have
this because of the he said yeah this is
on me and i got to make some changes
where do i start yeah and this starts
with saying stuff out loud to somebody
else but still once he even though he's
that that's a really good first line
rung on the ladder he's still got to get
up under it
otherwise it's going to just his parts
of his heart are going to leave that's
he needs to he knows to detach from the
heart before the stuff leaves that's
right that's exactly right that's a
great way to put that
wow this isn't a matter of just throwing
stuff away you know in america we've all
got just about everybody's got stuff
it's of some kind i get that
i'll be happy if i could just get that
card i'll be happy if i could buy
billions and billions of dollars that we
have in storage was a billion square
foot of storage space yeah i don't know
it's ridiculous yeah yeah we spend more
on storing stuff than most countries gdp
bonkers stuff that we don't use yeah
we're the only country in the world that
when someone moves they have a box
labeled seldom used kitchen items
it's like yeah i've gotta
i i'll be happy when
i'll be happy i get that thing from
ronco that's the big difference the two
sets of knives can you be happy without
that gun could you be happy without that
car would it be cool and nice of course
it would
will i still be worth being loved if i
don't have that yeah i quit buying cars
for other people a long time ago that's
that's another thing's going broke but i
still got really nice cars again i got
really nice cars but they're for me i
love that just because i like driving it
and i don't really care whether you like
it or not because i like it yeah that's
a whole different thing than i used to
do in my 20s whole different thing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsay show in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage zach and becky are with
us hey guys how are you great how are
you better than i deserve where do you
guys live uh fargo north dakota fargo
north dakota it's a bit of a halt to
nashville just a little bit whoo did
your driver fly we flew
i guess i hope so my goodness how cold
is it there right now
i don't want to know
that is a great answer says the guy in
shorts in tennessee
i like it all right how much debt did
you guys pay off 170 000. very good how
long did this take
four and a half years or so wow
and your range of income during that
time 45 to 105. oh nice jump okay cool
what do y'all do for a living i stay at
home with the girls and zach flies
fly you're a pilot yeah yeah i do a
small cargo uh company fly ups right
under contract very cool that you're a
superhero that's fantastic yeah this is
worth the cape yeah so the uh 170 000 in
debt was what
car and student loans whoa sally mae got
a big chunk huh yeah yeah unfortunately
flight school oh flight school oh there
it is all right well she still had to be
kicked out yes ugly woman didn't need
her own bedroom in your house all right
i like it way to go you guys how long
you been married five and a half years
okay so one year into marriage you
decide go gangbuster on this tell us
about what happened
um during our like marriage prep course
we um
had a financial um
teacher i guess during our like weekend
retreat thing whatever and it happened
to be one of zach's professors that he
looked up to so it was like we already
kind of know his
story and
yeah so he shared his story and we kind
of thought it was really cool and we
kind of dropped it after that for a
little bit and then so he kind of had a
ramsey story or yeah oh yeah he did the
whole thing and he
recommended your total money makeover
buck okay you did none of it immediately
correct yeah right because we were still
in school you know there's not so much
we can do you know what we thought and
what student listens to the professor
exactly you know it takes like six
months to brew you know okay so you're
married yes a year in
what woke you up what was like oh god we
got to do this um it was like a couple
months after we got married we read the
book together
and then
just started knocking them out the first
year we were pretty strong and then
i was teaching at the time
we got pregnant we thought you can't do
this when you're pregnant you know so we
kind of laid back a little bit went
davish
we ended up moving to sioux falls south
dakota for
six months
i stopped teaching because i stayed at
home with our oldest daughter abby
and
zach started at this current job he has
now but like a
lower
low salary yeah lower on the totem pole
um we moved back up to fargo because
there was a better opportunity with the
job
now he's kind of like the head guy of
fargo so that's cool
bumped up our salary
had another kid in the midst
and just kept working on our salary
and her brother met with some
smartvestor pros in iowa and we're like
oh well we should look into that too and
so stop the like davish and white
gazelle intense oh okay yeah finally
figured it out so babies and moves we
turned the heat up and down yeah yeah
and finally turned the heat up and
knocked it out so then after we met with
um tana our smartvestor pro
she kind of kicked us in the pants and
had us set a goal and we actually
knocked that goal out of the water all
right there we go fantastic game on hey
i like it you got there yeah yeah you
got there i like it it's a good and
that's a real story that's not somebody
that's too fake to be believed y'all
really did this yeah the last like year
we paid um over a hundred thousand it
was a year and a half i guess over a
hundred thousand so so the vast majority
of it just lately yeah yeah wow so i've
met with a lot of students over the
years and they look at a number this
high
and they kind of just quit yeah like
that number's high and you all chipped
away at it for three years how did you
keep from getting frustrated and just
killing each other
um i mean we were kind of our biggest
killing him it was just that
yeah
no one would have ever found him right
yeah right right right
um but yeah it was just kind of you know
we wanted to see
the loan number go down and our money in
our pocket go up right change the family
tree for our girls so give them
something to look forward to instead of
just a mountain of debt so that was kind
of the big motivating factor and we just
wanted to live our lives instead of
paying out to the banks so have you had
that moment where you've paid off
everything and your check is deposited
and you get to keep all that yeah
so now it's going towards our house well
we had finished our six-month emergency
fund so now it's just
saving for a house that we don't have
right now so it's just
there's a lot like shifting the
intensity to yeah getting rid of well
now it's to get something you want to
get rid of something you hate right
right that's more fun yeah it is yeah
yeah good for you guys well done i'm
proud of you what do you tell people the
key to getting out of details
um stick to a budget um
we didn't have beans and rice
necessarily but off-brand mac and cheese
is really good yeah yeah i'm with you
all right
yeah second of the budget you know just
keeping an eye on all the little
purchases right the little adds up yep
the little things make a big difference
um
we sold a lot of stuff on like facebook
marketplace um raising our incomes acted
doordash for a while
so any little thing helps so what do you
tell people the key okay at the 18 month
mark you met with smart investor pro you
set a goal and that's when the intensity
kicked in and you never let up at during
that 18 months and did most of the work
during that time right yes what do you
tell people that key was um
what was it that all of a sudden went
okay fire on we're doing this i think
we're just tired of like being the
davish and like it's not really going
away very fast you know we just really
need to keep up with the intensity um i
think it was tana that had suggested
like writing down our
um
dead snowball and putting it on the
fridge so you see it all the time and
that didn't really affect him so much
but it was like in my face all day long
since i stayed home with the girls
um so and then just having all sorts of
like charts and stuff that you can color
in or whatever it was helpful for me
yeah anything visual yes it's helpful
yeah visual is very motivating yes is it
true that your
kids will survive if they don't have
everything that they wish yeah you know
they don't agree with that you know at
the time but you know you have to learn
how to say no when you're at the grocery
store and they want you know
all the fancy cereals that are garbage
for you anyway so it's actually gotten
to the point we're gonna go out to eat
one night and our older daughter she's
like well we can't go out to eat we have
to save for buying a house yeah
so we were like well we have gift cards
for that because we have gift cards from
christmas you know so
that's okay put the box back now we're
rationalizing to the six-year-old yeah
we have cereal out of the bag mommy yes
way to go and she's three and a half and
she's like we can't have chick-fil-a we
don't have money for that we have to
save for a house
perfect that's so perfect oh that's good
she's gonna be listening to my show in a
few years
[Laughter]
way to go you guys we're very proud of
you very impressive who were your
biggest cheerleaders outside the two of
you
um our girls i guess if it's outside the
two of us yeah and her brother was a
pretty big supporter too what about the
professor that he just oh he was in him
and
yeah we just didn't see him as often
since we left grand forks after that oh
actually yeah okay does he know you did
all this now yes he's watching right now
i think so yeah what's his name uh dan
malott all right we'll give him a shout
out very good thanks dan all right
now this is a life that was changed
right here well done i love it guys we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth how you can do it's
the number one bestseller and our gift
to you another number one bestseller
total money makeover gonna give you one
of those and you can give it away to
somebody and disturb them the way uh the
way prof did for you that'll be good
stuff so well done you two very well
done zach and becky fargo north dakota
170
thousand dollars paid off in four and a
half years most of it in the last 18
months making 45 to 105. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
yeah
what a great cup all
175 thousand dollars is a tall
clear whole mountain yeah it's a big
mountain to climb and most of it student
loans i mean and that's that's the big
topic out there that it can't be done it
can't to be done yes it can it can't yes
it can zach and becky from fargo north
dakota just did a mic drop yes it can be
done they did it and uh they're walking
social proof that you can too
so you can do it when you're pregnant
you could do it with your a kid you can
do it while you're renting you can do it
when you're trading jobs
you can do it you can do it you can do
it well it's just a matter it has to be
front and i like the front and center
thing with the visual yeah that just
gets in your face messes with you
constantly reminding you
it's very very good very good stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
drake is with us in kansas city hi drake
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
well
pretty much i
was lucky enough to live with the best
dad
anybody could ever ask for um
best friend growing up all that long
story short he passed away a few years
ago and
left me a pretty good chunk
of money
um it it's in a trust fund right now
i won't see any of it because i'm 25
i'm a college student right now i'm 22
so i've got about three years left to go
basically i i have a few ideas of kind
of what i should do and how i should
save it uh investments like real estate
and stuff like that down the road
um but pretty much i just wanted to see
kind of if you were me or if you were in
my shoes what what were
what would be some things you would do
with a big chunk like this how much is
it
um i've got about
550 000 in a 401k
uh and then about 438 in calf
and i've got about
18
18 000 in my own right now that i have
access to okay
and you're 22 how old was he
uh he was
53 when he passed away wow what happened
yeah
um
sadly it was a
terminal disease um lou gehrig's disease
so it was
[Music]
sorry for what you've been through yeah
okay i appreciate that but uh yeah a
couple of things i mean more than
anything you just need some principles
to guide you
okay instead of specific tactics let me
give you some principles
number one principle go slow
there's no reason to be fast
number two don't put money in anything
you don't understand
just because somebody says it they know
this or they know that or you read an
article on the internet god help you
don't do that
or because even dave ramsey said to do
it don't do it you don't put money in
something unless you understand it
if you understand it you can learn from
people like me
to where you understand it then you can
go forward but just because it's shiny
and flashy and cool and the cool kids
are all doing it does not mean you put
money in it as a matter of fact that
usually means you don't
um the other thing you can remember is
this having studied wealthy people for
the past 30 years
i find that their investing strategies
are by and large very boring
they're not super uber sophisticated
they don't do uh you know limited family
partnership double backflips there's no
weird stuff
all these things you hear
that the rich have secrets they really
don't
they go slow they know what they put
money in they understand it they don't
put money in something unless they
understand it and therefore they don't
lose it and it generally makes some
money but they're not trying to hit the
home run every time they're just trying
to make money on their money
just steady right and so uh it doesn't
matter what you put money in as much
long as you understand it and you know
you know what it is and you do it so um
you know so i know a lot about real
estate i grew up in the real estate
business my parents were in the business
when i was a kid i got my license when i
turned 18. i'm very very comfortable
with real estate consequently i have a
bunch of it
okay right but someone who's scared to
death and has never done it or never
dealt with a tenant you would want to go
super super slow
test it a little bit test it a little
bit test it a little bit it's second
nature for me though
okay
same thing with mutual funds i i really
do not have any investments personally
except mutual funds and real estate
that's all i have okay because i got
really comfortable with it doesn't have
to be sexy or cool if the cool kids
don't like it i don't really care i'm
not investing for them
right you know hey ramsay doesn't
understand dave ramsey's got several
hundred million dollars dave ramsey
understands something okay all right so
um you know that that's just
you know that that's but that's what i
find when i talk to
you know the uh you know you're the
person you're talking to if they've got
a little gray hair it's probably a good
idea
uh because i i was young and rich and
lost everything i didn't want his
opinion when i started surveying people
about how money works because he was an
idiot he lost everything that's me i'm
talking about so
but i did i did high leverage get rich
quick real estate and it bit me in the
butt
uh because i've violated a lot of common
sense rules so all of that to say do
that the last thing i'll tell you is
this in the multitude of counsel there
is safety
and so if i were a 25 year old
millionaire sudden sudden millionaire
i would uh build a board of directors
for my life not that tells me what to do
a board of advisors i'd have a high
quality insurance broker an estate
planner a tax attorney
an investment broker
all that i can call and speak to
about taxes about insurance about real
estate a good real estate person i'd
have a little collection of people that
i i you don't necessarily have to call
them all together at any time
but they need to um they're there to
advise you with the heart of a teacher
they're not there to tell you what to do
uh they're not there to be arrogant and
act like they have their god's gift to
whatever
um
the uh if you get if you sense that
arrogance run from them uh but get some
teachers in your corner because you have
to go slow and you have to invest only
in things you don't understand the then
whether you do understand the one thing
i'd add dave is i didn't understand this
until
i got older and started having money
don't don't use this money to leverage
this money to go get some more um the
number of folks who said hey you want to
put 10 in on this or 25 in on this or
hey we're all going in to buy this
apartment you want to put 15 on this
they they like me as a friend but what
they really want is my money to make
their picture of what they want to do
come true and it's easy to take that
money and think you can parse it out and
make a bunch of people happy and make a
bunch of money ever you end up spreading
it all out and you end up wait you can
lose that money quick yeah right i the
only ship on sale is a partnership i'm
not in any partnerships
i own it
or i'm not in it it's okay and that
means i got lots of friends that do all
kinds of stuff like that but i don't i
don't do it i'm just my life is low
drama
very low drama right it's just downright
boring
you know and i kind of like it i like it
that way that's right that's a play was
intentional max is in canada hey max
let me try again
there he is max is in canada what's up
max
hi how are you doing sir great how can
we help
great i'm going to try and be as
straight and transformative as i
possibly can i'll just give you a little
overview first right now i'm just
finishing up my last year of university
i'm graduating this may
i have enough funds to be able to pay
off my student loans which i've done as
well as 10 000 for my initial starting
emergency fund i guess for six months
where'd it go
um yeah the one thing i wanted to throw
into is i read ken's proximity principle
book this summer and it was an absolute
game changer so if there's any other
university students watching or anything
i highly recommend that book my question
for you today is i've been able to land
a full-time job that i'm going to be
starting this summer after graduation
the company currently does not offer
anything in terms of retirement matching
and i'm kind of looking at my different
retirement offer options i know that you
recommend about 15
so i'm looking here in canada we have a
tfsa which is similar to a roth ira
um but that's not a traditional
retirement account how this one works is
i can put in 6 000 per year and that
money grows tax-free i'm wondering when
it comes to retirement would it make
more sense to max that out first before
putting money into a traditional
retirement account
uh we tell folks stateside to do roth
before they do traditional because it
grows tax-free
and if i'm understanding what you just
presented to me i'm not an expert on
canadian retirement plans okay but if i
understand what you just said this is
more of a roth is six 000 and it grows
tax-free the traditional grows
uh after tax and i mean it's an it's a
pre-tax investment and it grows with
taxation on the whole account correct
yes sir okay so just like our plan state
side the way you described it it's a
traditional versus a roth so we always
tell people to do a roth first
um because the tax free growth is going
to be a
it's going to amount to a whole lot more
than than the
obviously the after tax effect of the
other other account so pretty simple
sounds like you really got this on the
run max way to go and all the parents
out there with little kids
i want you to imagine
15 20 years from now
your kids in the last semester of
college
do you want him to have a conversation
like he just had how do i start
investing my money after i've got my
emergency fund or do you want them to be
making a phone call saying how do i pay
all the student loan stuff off and that
starts when your kids are really young
with some decisions you make
conversations you have as parents have
those conversations have a plan
there we go nicely done
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life
your money your mental health your
relationships your job your career
all of it's on the line right here at
the ramsay show thank you for joining us
logan is going to start off this hour in
dayton ohio hey logan what's up
hey dave john how you all doing better
than we deserve how can we help all
right going to be on the show i'll get
uh right to it um so i've been watching
your youtube videos online for about two
weeks now kind of a really strange way
to end up finding it but i'm very
thankful that i did
my parents taught me a lot about
finances growing up so thankfully uh
where i'm at in life i'm actually on
baby step six i'm 24 years old i have a
mortgage now
with my house in dayton ohio and i had a
question regarding it
so
again i started watching two weeks ago
um so i'll let you know some of the
decisions i made not quite in line um
but i got a house in november on a
30-year va mortgage
um so right now i have it financed for
161
dollars
um i have my emergency savings all up uh
everything like that's good um but i
have thirty five thousand dollars
that is in uh mutual funds that my
parents set up for me for college um i'm
in the military so our college is paid
for thankfully um so trying to find out
what i want to do with that i'm looking
at being here between three and five
years and dayton um so in time with my
parents a little bit of confusion and
trying to figure out what will be the
best option is it to put that money you
know onto the principal and just try to
try to knock that down as quick as
possible or to keep it in like a mutual
funds because it is it is growing pretty
decently in there
[Music]
well thank you for your service
oh absolutely my pleasure what do you do
in the military
uh so on the air force uh i work uh
easiest way to describe would be like
military police so basically got you
okay cool good for you
very nice thank you well um
our normal process is we try to
determine what the shortest distance
between where you are right now
and wealthy is
what's the shortest distance
okay
and having studied wealthy people and
people that built wealth for 30 years
and lots of data on the subject
we have found that the first one to five
million dollars in net worth that people
get
generally comes from two areas um
the uh
the the wonderful built up retirement
plan in your case the tsp
um and uh and a paid for house
those are the two things that we talk to
the typical millionaire
with their first one to five million
dollars of net worth
is usually their paid for home
and their retirement accounts
their roth iras and their 401ks and that
kind of stuff and that's where it is and
so
uh you can try to get there other ways
but
we find very few people that do
i i don't i you know the number of
millionaires that we talked to when we
studied 10 000 of them that said i
borrowed money on my house and put it
into the stock market because the stock
market was doing really good and that
made me a millionaire
was really close to zero hardly any of
them did
everybody talks about that
and a lot of
bad financial advisors recommend that
but it's in real practice actually
finding wealthy people who really did it
there's not many of them
and so that's what i go with i say let's
get the house paid off and let's build
up your retirement accounts now you're
going to be moving but the good news
about paying that 35 000 down on your
principal is when you sell your house
they're going to give you a check for
the equity it's not like you spent the
money
you just moved it over onto the house
your net worth doesn't change
right okay so yeah that way you know
whenever i do move you know that's just
going forward to equity
yeah be sure be sure you sell the house
when you leave don't have long distance
landlording everywhere you
get stationed you end up with a house
and a rental property and you end up
with 17 rental properties in 17 places
you were stationed over the last 30
years or something in the military
career but
don't do that that's a disaster um but
so sell it when you leave and then you
may even rent depending on how far how
long you're going to be in the next
place
but um just just again don't go with
what
they said and i heard they're the worst
financial planners on the planet
everybody's got a dead gum opinion
they're the worst mental health
practitioners they're worth marriage
counselors the worst pet owners it's
like you know the current version of
going to the old old school barber shop
like floyd's on maybe a rfd right you
sit around a bunch of old men and
they're all going to tell you how to do
something because they don't know how to
do yep and the current version of that's
google in it except that that
accepted that barbershop had some common
sense well they they
looked at the guy down the way and said
you're an idiot you don't tell that boy
that and then they would say no you
don't tell there was you could hear it
back and forth google tells you exactly
what you want to hear yeah and you know
if you're if you get sick the last thing
you need to do is google it
because it will scare you because you're
dead
you're dying of whatever it is you're
dead and there's also a natural uh
homeopathic answer for whatever you've
got essential oils
essential oils death essential oils
special homeopathic witch doctors rather
i mean there's every it's something
everywhere dave the letters we're going
to get on by the essential oil people
really care i mean it's just it's okay
if you want to do those things they're
going to they're going to poke pins in a
doll but they uh but but you know you're
going to get whatever you want to do
but the thing is yeah so that's it they
said and i heard don't you know when
broke people are giving you financial
advice run power did it's a good rule
right there run david's in san antonio
hi david welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing great man
what's up
hey uh my wife and i are in a bit of a
conundrum we don't know what to do and
we're hoping for some guidance
we seven years ago purchased our dream
home and built it
and then life happened and i got a job
across town we got another home
and we didn't sell the dream home
we continue to rent it been a rental for
about four years now
our primary home we owe 370 on and our
rental home
we owe 320
and our tenant has been in that house
for two years
is requesting to purchase it
for
fair market value we got a cma done and
she's willing to give us that market the
cma price how am i and also willing to
not use a military
uh 480.
okay she got 100 grand coming your way
uh after taxes and everything our tax
guy said we'd looking at about 130.
okay
all right good and the deal is
the wife wants to sell and put a 120 or
130 down on the house our primary home
and recast the loan and save some money
i
am looking at
wanting to continue running it and
hoping i can sell it for 200 or 250 or
300 grand
what's your household income
about 170 okay if you're going to keep
it develop a plan to pay it and your
home off
within five or six years let's get with
it get it cleaned up if you're if you're
gonna sell it you don't need to recast
your mortgage just throw the debt throw
it at the mortgage and then let's get
your mortgage paid off as soon as
possible and then save up and pay cash
for the next rental
because this didn't become a rental by
plan it was by default
you did not buy this house to be a
rental
you ended up with it being a rental so
is it a good rental i don't know
you can decide that but if you're going
to keep them you got to get them paid
off now
get with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
mataya is with nothing star she's up i'm
sorry metallia you're up next uh darcy's
up in washington dc hi darcy how are you
hi i am so excited to be speaking to you
guys thank you guys so much for your
help sure what's up
um okay i'll make a long story short
here i am 33 years old i am not married
i have no kids i'm in baby steps four
and six
and my question is what should i do with
an extra two thousand dollars to hit my
15 retirement goal if i can't do a
backdoor raw due to the pro rata rule
so you got an aggregation problem you
got too much in the
in the traditional
i do i have about 80k in a traditional
ira yeah okay
uh you can just drop it into a mutual
fund i mean that's all you need to do
the point is just to try to get make
sure you're saving into something uh
what i do in non-retirement mutual fund
investing is i invest in what's called a
low
turnover mutual fund which means they
don't sell the stocks inside the mutual
fund very often
and um
uh hardly at all like a five percent
turnover ratio would be called a low
turnover mutual fund a good example of
that is just an s p 500 fund uh your
smart investor pro can hook you up with
one or you can just go buy a smart buy
buy a s p 500 somewhere they're not
non-commissioned no-brainer
you know you know there's nothing to it
you just buy it and hold it uh because
as the money grows you don't pay taxes
on it
uh like um like a rental property you
don't pay taxes on the value increasing
until you sell it
so if you're churning inside that fund
all the time you're always paying taxes
on that sale exactly okay and if they if
they buy and hold the stocks inside the
fund and you hold the fund
then you've got capital gains growth
okay meaning you don't pay taxes on it
until you sell it so what you just
mentioned aggregation i didn't
understand half the words you used what
does that mean
what's that mean
okay that's a rule that the irs has that
does not allow a roth ira or backdoor
roth ira if you have a large
as a percentage of your world a large
traditional
ira okay so another thing you could do
you could start to move some of that
traditional over to roth and pay the
taxes on it
that would have the same effect but i
really wouldn't do that until you got
your house paid off i think you're
probably just putting some money in
mutual fund i'll make it easy enough
matea is with us in eugene oregon
hi mateo how are you
i'm doing good thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
all right so i am uh 18 years old i
recently live on my own
i have
an income but
the majority of that goes to paying all
of these financial goals i now have i am
currently in college and about to
graduate with my associates
but because of
all the recent events i
i don't have the money to pay for
college and i don't want to just stop
going until i have the money because i'm
so close so kind of hoping for some
guidance
this sounds like you suddenly left home
i did yes why
um i had a very bad moving situation
with my my parents
at home and i needed to get out
okay i'm sorry yeah are you safe now
i am yes no i i live on my own um no one
knows where i live so it's kind of nice
okay that's not a bad thing um
it is a bad thing that you've had to go
through this but i mean it's a good
thing that nobody knows so uh
what do you make
i make um
an average of 1600 a month between two
jobs um on a good month it can be like
18 or 1900. what do you do
i am a part-time nanny and part-time
barista
okay
what are you going to school for
um general studies but focus in
psychology okay
and you're almost through with your
associates
yes i am
okay is have you got the money to finish
that
i do not no i am almost as in like i
could it's so it's a long associates
because i started when i was pretty
young and i didn't take a full load of
classes um so i i would say like by fall
term i would be graduated
okay
all right okay rule number one is not
college
rule number one is existence
sustainability
food shelter
clothing
transportation
utilities
in the eighth grade when i was in school
we called that necessities
okay
and so that's the that's the main thing
you have to do right there
until you get that done we don't think
about the other
and if you delay college whoopie doopty
you're 18 you're safe you've got time
you'll get there
but your big thing is safety
and security meaning that you have a
place to live you have food you have the
lights on
okay because what you're going through
is very scary i mean albeit terrifying
am i wrong
what yeah no you do not know yeah and so
let's just pretend for a second
the way i the way i my my brains work is
if we could get your income from sixteen
hundred to three thousand and you didn't
go to school
i think you could breathe a little
better
and then let's start talking about how
we get back to school
okay
does that i mean what if you made four
thousand dollars in a month but you
didn't go to school you'd feel better
than being terrified and going to school
so yeah yeah for sure and we're not
gonna do that as a permanent way of life
i believe in education and i want you to
have a a track that you're on to have a
career that's not a barista okay a long
term you don't want to be a 48 year old
barista you want to move on you want to
have a career right
you want to become
you know whatever it is you want to
become and i want you to get there but i
want to do that from a place of strength
not a strength of not a place of terror
john yeah
can i
matia can i be real honest with you
yeah what you've done so far is very
brave
and few people have the strength and
bravery to do what you did which is to
keep yourself safe even though it meant
going off on your own
and this is a moment
when people in your situation
bury themselves in short-term decisions
that will haunt you for
years and years and years okay
so hear me say
commit now
i will not borrow money i will no longer
be
trapped by anybody and you just escaped
one situation don't jump into another
thing
okay i agree yeah you are 18 about to
finish your associates do you real
you're two years ahead of everybody
okay
so slow down and become safe
become safe you honey are worth more
than sixteen hundred dollars a month
you just are
you work hard you're so far ahead i can
tell you're a hard worker you're brave
you're strong you can do
really hard stuff i want to see you get
a job where you're working full-time and
then going to your associate's degree in
the evenings or in the mornings you can
figure that out i know you can
and you made a you made a big grown-up
decision and you have to work real hard
okay this is gonna be hard the next
couple years full-time nanny might make
three to four grand right
um
it depends on the need i i live in a
um i'm just naming for it for a family
i've been with somebody i know i know
you're a babysitter
yeah i want you i want you to change to
a nanny and make three thousand dollars
a month
okay market yourself there and this is
double your income yeah this family
probably is your safety lifeline is that
right
um yes yeah they are i actually um have
a boyfriend we're planning to get
married um sometime this summer as well
so
okay
i want you to get somebody that is an
adult that you can
sit down and talk about all your plans
with because right now you're running
and i don't want you to run into a
marriage you're not a hundred percent in
on i don't want you to run into student
loans just to finish i don't want you to
run into a job that's paying you half of
what you're worth right now you're just
running for your life and i want you to
run it or walk to an adult one or two or
three people in your life that you can
sit down and say here's what i'm
thinking and they'll go
oh honey slow down make your school
decision
make your career decision
make your marriage decision from
strength
and john and i are saying that
[Music]
you're probably
not feeling super strong right now
so any of those three decisions right
now are really really tenuous
i'm not saying you shouldn't get married
not saying you shouldn't finish school
i'm not saying
you know that you're not going to have a
career but i think you need to get a
financial strength of sustainability
and then go oh from strength i'm going
to decide to get married not from
weakness
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage kathleen is with us hey
kathleen how are you hello i'm nervous
that's okay we've never lost a patient
you're gonna make that sounds good
you're gonna make it where do you live i
live in spring texas cool did you grow
up there um no i'm from up north and
then i went down there i was recruited
to teach oh very good what do you teach
um i'm a school administrator now i've
lived in texas for 33 years okay well
you're a tax on that i'm a texan yeah
once you've been there 33 years they
they make it official somewhere around
then i think i guess
it's about 30 minutes once you're in
you're oh 30 minutes they jump you in
and you've got the tattoos we know
you're in it all right that's it well
welcome so how much debt did you pay off
i paid off 74 400
way to go and how long did this take you
17 months wow and your range of income
during that time um i make about a
hundred thousand and with my side
hustles i made 32 000. so
132. okay cool what's your side hustle
um i started uber eats i did that for a
while and then i got into umpiring with
my
boyfriend so we started umpiring we do
that all the time and then i have kids
that move back home so i decided that
they could help pay for the mortgage why
not that's a good thing so what are you
umpire
softball softball girls what age um
anywhere from six organized sports to
umpires no sir
no sir
that is because we could solve the
ukraine crisis pretty quickly
that's been a truism since this time
here overseas wow if you're behind the
plate you take your mask off at times
and just kind of stare them down
yes
and they look at the floor of the ground
and they're like i'm sorry yeah
no not
that's right throwing them out i love it
so what's it like what's it like being a
an administrator of a school and then
hopping out of work and then going to do
ubereats do you ever show up to the
house of a student
no i have made sure that i have
delivered in a different area okay all
right yeah that could be that's that's
horrible that'd be weird that's i mean
that's putting it all out there yeah all
right so what kind of debt was the 74
000 um it was personal loan i had
medical loan that i paid off um i had my
ex-husband's student loan that i still
had to pay off because i co-signed on it
which i would recommend never ever doing
um he passed away but i still paid it
off
um
and just kind of a collage
oh wow so i had about 64 000 but in that
time as i was ubereating and different
things like that i had a car accident
somebody ran into me and drove off so i
had to purchase a new car within that
time
and then also
my youngest got married oh wow so we
cash flowed
11 000. okay wow you've covered a bunch
of stuff yeah
so what inspired you to do all this 17
months ago what was the story what
started you um i met a man um that's
sitting over here and he's always been
my
cheerleader um he's live the dave ramsey
baby steps forever and
he just kept on encouraging me you know
that this is the way we do it we would
go do things or
go places and we always listen to the
ramsay show and
all the time and he just told me once he
said you know hey send me your finances
you know through email limps set up a
payoff quote and everything you know a
program for you and i was like no i
don't talk about finances i don't want
to talk about finances because i didn't
think it was ever possible even though
you hear all these people say it i just
didn't think it was possible
and i said okay well here's my finances
and i walked out the door and he's like
you don't want to talk about it i'm like
no
but um finally he called me that evening
and we talked about it and he showed me
how it was possible and how i would
start with the snowball effect and how i
would pay a little bit on one and then i
would pay that off and then i add that
to another one and he had a spreadsheet
all made for me of my income and what i
would pay off and how i could do it and
i mean you were spoon fed he was just
straight up i mean he just did it for
you this is awesome yes and yeah and 17
months later you're free of something
you didn't think was possible correct
wow my paychecks would come in from
ubereats on tuesdays like i would never
take the cash out on it yeah so in
mondays i would take my money from
softball and i would go deposited in the
bank so i would make one payment on
mondays from softball and then i make my
tuesday payments for my ubereats so if i
didn't have softball on the weekend then
i was doing ubereats um i did either
ubereats or i did league ball softball
during the week how far into the 17
months did you go
wait a minute this is gonna work
i would say it took about six months
honestly really because i mean i kept on
thinking i got some things paid off but
i don't know the smaller ones i thought
well okay well that was just getting
trusted him
to put the system in place and then you
trusted his
she was a huge cheerleader for me yeah
just a huge motivator and cheerleader
because you weren't sure it was going to
work in six months you did it anyway i
kept on doing it i enjoyed what i was
doing i'm being an administrator i'm not
in the classroom anymore so really being
out there on the ball field with the
girls and everything like that i mean
that's true turned in to be a passion
for me just being with them and stuff
not the parents but the girls and
somebody's got to care for those kids
and so that's been really fun just being
out there and doing it so i would say
maybe five to six months but um when i
got the biggest when i got my car paid
off i think that's when i was just like
oh my gosh i got that paid off and that
was the biggest one i remember that was
in january
how long has it been since you were
completely debt-free how many years ago
too many like when you started your
working life probably probably probably
had debt your whole adult life yes sir
yeah okay yes sir what kind of freedom
um
did you experience when
you paid off that student loan
because that that that's that's wrapped
up into some other feelings into some
other into loss
there had to have been a cathartic
moment of
goodbye
it was it was pretty unreal and
um it's really weird but the month i did
it was also the month that my youngest
got married
and so um my
ex-mother-in-law was here and you know
and i told her and i mean so it was
really uh
rejoicing you know i have to give her a
shout out she told me she said um kathy
said you know
um i told you all about dave ramsey 30
years ago and you never listened to me
and yada yada
oh what a mother-in-law i told you so i
told you so what an
ex-mother-in-law that's right yeah but
um you know she was there for the
wedding that's all it's just all that so
yeah it was a big release and it was a
big accomplishment now i just hope my
kids follow in my footsteps and they
learned before i did yeah amen
amen way to go i'm proud of you oh thank
you good work good work very well done
okay now when you back
up and you look at the whole process
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
having that budget having that budget
and sticking to it and then when you do
your side hustles um really making sure
you're taking that money and you're
putting it towards your debt so you're
putting that towards whatever you're
paying off at the time i think that was
the biggest thing
of just any extra money i had then you
just put it towards that debt
that speeds everything up substantially
very much so
incredible 17 months later she's free
just like that boom
changes everything everything you don't
meet a lot of really great longhorns man
but this guy's done all right he's
decked out dave he's decked out in all
his gear he went to the wrong texas
college but i applaud him he did a good
job
did a good job he's done a wonderful job
now that you're free how's it feel
it feels fantastic and i've saved money
so i've started on you know
building up my next step
and um my financial security um but i've
also taken some of the money to do some
fixes on the house that i needed to do
just kind of making sure that
everything is working order good for you
well done it's been wonderful well done
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you we want that to be the next
chapter in your story go on and be a
millionaire now you're on your way thank
you you're on your way how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth and
how you can too also a copy of the total
money makeover book
that uh eight million people have now
read you can give that to one of your
kids maybe maybe get the one that just
got married maybe get them moving in the
right direction
so good stuff all right it's kathleen
from spring texas 74 000 paid off in 17
months making 132 with the side hustles
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
i'm dead free
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
john's new book own your past change
your future is on pre-sale the not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness
dealing with all kinds of trauma
getting connected to a community change
your thoughts and actions so here's the
thing john that that we're experiencing
with the sale of the book the book is
selling like hot cakes by the way and if
you want to pre-order the book uh i'll
go ahead and tell you and get it for 20
and what comes with it is pretty
incredible
a month of weekly one-on-one therapy
through our partners at better health is
included
that's unbelievable deal
the better health people really believe
in john
and uh as we do but boy they have really
stepped up and made this pr pre-order
purchase
the bargain of the century uh right now
and here's why that's important dave
that
for years uh the last several years
there's been a shortage people they get
the courage up to say hey i want to go
get a go get an appointment with a local
counselor
um with a local therapist and
can't get in you get put on a six-month
wait list and we just we're talking
about an article that came out today
talking about the waitlist across the
country
and
the better help their
guarantee is they'll someone will call
you within 24 hours and so my fear was
someone's going to close this book and
say all right it's time and i got some
stuff i got to deal with not everyone
who reads is going to need therapy but
there's time
and then guaranteed if you read this
book you'll be in there that's right but
uh they're gonna pick it up and then go
cool in eight months i'll uh i'll get
back on that so man that better help
deal with what it does it does wake you
up and go there's a there's a chance
that i don't have to live
with them with with the mental issues
i'm dealing with that's right i can i
can get the i can get past that and i
need some help starting today i need
some help and this better help thing
helps you get it incredible yeah yeah i
love it really grateful for them
the the whole premise of the book and um
it is just to change the story yeah the
story the the stories of our life as you
wrote
um good and bad
are how we operate in our brains
and uh you can be set free from some of
the bad stories that keep running
they're on their own loop in our brains
aren't they they're on automatic
automatic response over and over and
over yeah and you can just even just
even realizing that's what's happening
and it doesn't have to be this way and
then you can
the challenge there is then what do i do
and that's what we walk through yeah own
your past it's there we're not going to
deny it it happened
change your future you don't have to be
what happened to you hey and i found it
today uh i don't even know this is going
out today but they
down they uploaded uh so if you go to my
normal podcast the dr john deloney show
they released today as a special release
the first chapter of the audiobook as a
bonus yeah so you can go check out if
you want to if you're interested i'm
thinking about i don't know the first
chapter of the of the audiobook's been
released today on with the podcast and
so you can go check it out
as read by the author oh yeah you know
and this is the first audio book that i
wrote the forward and i actually voiced
the forward oh yeah that's strange that
is true i don't know who voiced the
forwards and the other ones i wrote but
it's the only one i've ever voiced
probably kelly she did it no one even
knows yeah well nobody reads it forward
that's why nobody cares
but uh all it all i said was it's a
great book you should read it or
something like that so
uh dash forward yeah so own your past
change your future by dr john deloney
the latest or the newest or the soonest
the next number one best seller it's not
yet because it's not out yet technically
but it is on pre-sale you can get it at
ramseysolutions.com
and get yourself signed up and uh man
you get a lot of so you get the ebook
and the audiobook all as part of the
package along with a
month of
free one-on-one weekly therapy through
our partners at better help dave is with
us in indianapolis hi dave welcome to
the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up hey i just had a few quick questions
so
i've been saving for a home for what
seems like a very long time
um i'm 33 years old i was just recently
married last year
my wife is 27
and i have a 13 year old son
um
we just purchased the house this year i
paid it off
and i have zero debt
and i was just wondering uh what what
would your next step be i i need a plan
and a path for my future
okay so you're 100 debt free
yes and your household income is what
uh 46 okay very well done so man very
well done
okay there's only three things you can
do with money
you can invest it to create more money
you can give it in generosity
and you can enjoy it
you should always do all three
and you can decide the percentages
because you have done an incredible job
and have set yourself up to win but i
would not recommend giving all of your
income away but i would always give some
of it i would not recommend investing
all of your income but i would always
invest some of it and i would not
recommend consuming or enjoying all of
your income but i would consume and
enjoy some of it
so what are you going gonna do with it
yeah
uh well i did purchase a house it's not
my dream home it needs a lot of fixing
um someone you're living in
yes okay
oh so you got so you're gonna have to
spend some money on the house
yes how much
i have no idea probably
at least ten and fifteen thousand okay
we'll just put that in your budget man
that's your new that's one of your new
payments you pay yourself for the
renovation
okay i just paid it off last week so uh
that's kind of what i was thinking but
uh yeah
congratulations absolutely and and
you're that's that's part of your
enjoyment money and then part of your
money is investing
and part of your money is generosity and
just keep on man you're doing a great
job
very well done
wow yeah and
man
i've heard this call more often than i
would have thought whereas someone
crossed as a major milestone and they
kind of have this moment of feeling
untethered um i'm
i just let the ski rope go and i'm kind
of all over the place
just get a new plan
just just be intentional about what
comes next right whether it's saving for
your house retirement give a chunk of
money away go do something fun go on a
vacation you paid your house off man
celebrate um don't let this paralyze you
yeah here's the thing if you will write
it down this much is going to this this
much is going a this much going to be
this much you're going to see
whatever it is
the simple written out formula that's
what we do with our money all right i
just opened my mail before i came down
here while i go i got i got a check from
the publisher from an old book years ago
but it's a nice little check still
selling
and i know i know exactly where that's
going to go i did not know that that
check was coming and i did not know
exactly how much it would be if i had
known it was coming because we don't
know until we get the statement in on
the royalties right but i do know
exactly what percentage of it is going
to generosity i know what percentage of
it is going to enjoyment and i know what
percentage of it is going to further
investing
because it's all preset on every dollar
that comes into the ramsey's household
these days and so um
and then that and then within each of
those categories here's how generosity
looks we do that through the foundation
in our case um and we tithe we're
christians so we give a 10th of our
income to our local church and here's
how the investing looks i'm going to buy
real estate i'm going to pay mutual
funds i got this next project i'm
working on over here i'm building up for
and over here some enjoyment here's
something sharon wants to do and
something we want to buy at the house or
do something and you know go on a trip
or whatever and so it's all laid out
it's all laid out it's kind of boring
but it's all very very very intentional
no one wins by accident right and then
says look i won how did that happen they
all go it was a series of progressive
incremental decisions intentional
decisions that caused you to win that's
right what winning always looks like in
mental health and marriage and parenting
in business and money
if we could convince the world that the
path forward
is boredom and consistency it's doing it
over and over again
we'd win systems systems create a good
system you know and just keep going one
of our buddies wrote a book that's been
on the number one on and off number one
and on and off it's been hanging out on
the best sellers for about a year atomic
habits well that's a couple years old
now yeah it's clear and that's all he
talks about he says you know people
don't win because they set goals they
win because they systematically work
incremental progress in atomic habits
small habits a series of small habits a
series of small habits and a constant
process to take you towards your goal
and you rise and fall to the level of
your system yep right yep and so you can
have all the goals in the world but if
your house is full of twinkies you don't
have a gym gym equipment you know it's
going to be tough for you you can lift
twinkies
into the mouth
over and over but yeah it's about your
systems man set yourself up for success
keep in mind those twinkies will last
500 years
which is exciting and out of your stuff
which is exactly why you should not
ingest those yes
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money your
relationships your mental health your
jobs and your careers this is the ramsay
show we're glad you're here open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five chad is in minneapolis hi chad
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks for having me on sure what's up
so um i'm in um kind of step five slash
upgrade to six uh quick backstory i've
got a 130 000 paid for home uh with a
hundred grand that grand in the bank and
we'll be looking to upgrade here
recently or in the future
um i think i might have the question but
my bait my salary was about 110 and then
through some restructuring negotiation
um within my organization i
got up to 120 salary with a
i got a 30 000 bonus and a 12 000 car
allowance so that brings me up to about
160. um there's not any income
restrictions on having a designated roth
401k through my employer is it or is
that no iras no income restrictions only
on iras
okay um
the old and then
and that so that's what sort of solved
that one my one question there is uh
because i'm i'm gonna be looking to
upgrade my house you're single right
i i am
engaged um so we've got we've got six
kids together so it's a very busy
household um
so we need we need a little more room to
grow um you've been you got six kids and
you've been too busy to get married
uh no so uh i have i have four children
from a previous marriage you have two
from a previous year you had six
together you're just trying to just
still feeling it out a little bit to see
if this is the one yeah okay
yeah yeah
um
but but i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
receiving a a check uh
from
i never took care of it through the
divorce uh of about twenty eight
thousand dollars through a qdro uh for
my ex's pensions
um does it make sense to
that you can roll that you can just roll
to an ira
right but does it is it is it very anti
brand
to
pay to pay the penalties get that in
cash so i can have a larger down payment
on a bigger
house
it doesn't really matter if it's
anti-ramsey
just you're going to give the government
a whole big pile of money that i
wouldn't do
i mean it's not well you've got a ramsey
thing it's you know you're going to
you're going to give the government 30
30
you're borrowing extra down payment
money at 30 interest right
no but i wouldn't give the government 30
of my money earned that money i would
have been i would have paid that same
yeah but i mean i have a pile of money i
have the opportunity to borrow money at
30 interest to put more on my down
payment on my house i think i'll pass
and you didn't earn it yeah
like
if i got hit by a meteor i'd probably do
things differently today but i didn't
right so you didn't earn the money and
so i yeah i wouldn't would you take out
a um an additional small loan at 30
percent to down put down payment on your
house
no same thing same thing man
same math
so yeah just roll it to a traditional
max out your roth a 401k over at work or
up to 15
and then save like a crazy person and
finish up your down payment get it get
the down payment as big as you can get
it you're heading in the right direction
so i know it feels like you had a pile
of money coming and it's gonna feel so
good it's not it's just not no it's
you're gonna give a pile of money to
government if you do that and we don't
we don't give money to the government
it's not a ramsay thing though it's just
a it's just a math thing
you know it's you know it's not you
stole that principle from math dave
[Laughter]
yeah you're full of one-liners on this
particular call i'm just saying
cubana is with us in baton rouge hey
cubana what's up
hi ramsay can you hear me absolutely how
can we
okay so
my husband and i we opened up a company
back in may of 2021
and i wanted to know how can i make sure
that our personal and business finances
is ready for the tax season
okay
uh back in may of 2021 i would have
started this if you haven't you're gonna
have to go back and do it starting now
does the company have a separate
checking account that you only do
business out of
yes it does okay if you only put
business money or income into that
account and you only paid business
expenses out of that account and you
didn't do it anywhere else that account
the income and outcome of that account
will show what your business has done
because it shows your revenue and it
shows your expenses and what's left is
called profit
um it does but
honestly i've never really looked at it
because i didn't know what to look for
and i recently started looking at it
when i found um
i found you on youtube i think or maybe
it was an influence on instagram not
sure but i started looking and i was
getting a little insecure about the
members
because i know we have an audit coming
up and made for the company
what is it called workers comp
oh a workers comp audit fast
agency yeah yeah i wouldn't be i
wouldn't be freaked out about it jump
online at ramseysolutions.com and click
on uh elp it stands for endorsed local
provider find a tax person there in
baton rouge that we endorse they
probably also do small business
bookkeeping and you'll be able to pay
them a fee to untangle your barrel of
fish hooks
so basically you got like three ski
ropes all wrapped together and twisted
up and that's all of your numbers but
they're all there they're all in the
barrel we just got to get them out and
untangle them and show your proper
income your proper expenses and your
proper profit and um that'll also help
you get your taxes ready for 2022 and
it'll set you up perfectly for your
workers comp audit so you can know what
to pay properly on the workers comp it
should if you have all your expenses in
there in that account or anywhere where
you can get your hands on them then you
can you can go back and develop a profit
loss statement for the six months of
2021 and that's really what needs to
happen and a bookkeeper can help you do
that this is it's really sixth grade
math and organization
is all it is it's not it's not a super
difficult uh intellectual exercise
anybody can do it
it's just a matter you've got to get all
the expenses
for each month categorize them by
category all the income for each month
categorize it by category the difference
in the two is your profit
and uh if you do that six times for six
months you have your you have your your
income statement or your profit loss
statement for the year 2021 since you
opened in june around june 1st of 2021
and you'll be there
but if you need some help you can pay
somebody a few hundred dollars if you if
it's the company's making money to do it
for you
i personally can't stand to do that kind
of stuff it drives me nuts so it's one
of the first things i'd pay somebody
else to do
but uh but i know how to do it i just
don't want to do it
and just lazy in that way i don't want
it's just
it's a it's
yeah yeah but if you want
if you want to do it we have people that
we can hook you up to do the right
that's how it works this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
seems like january 1st is two years ago
how your resolution's going
if you're like most people you hit it
hard in january and by valentine's day
they were done
well you can reach all of your money
goals this year but it takes
accountability
it takes intentionality it takes a plan
to get them done and you get all of this
by joining a financial peace university
class
you'll go through our proven money plan
with other people who will help you stay
motivated they'll hold you accountable
they'll encourage you because they're
trying to get out of debt and build
wealth just like you are financial peace
university classes are both in person
and they're online there's no excuse not
to give this a try
you can get back on track with your
money goals almost 10 million people
have been through this class and have
had successful results not only getting
out of debt but many of them have gone
on to become baby steps millionaires
following the baby steps that's where we
wrote the number one best-selling book
from so get started for free
a free trial for financial peace
university
at ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu adam is with us in atlanta hi adam
welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys thank you for having me sure
what's up
so i'm uh i've made some pretty pretty
dumb mistakes and i'm uh i'm pretty
terrified of making some more so i was
hoping i could get some advice on uh
i guess how i can move forward with
getting a house
i've got some car debt from some pretty
stupid mistakes um been there done that
trying to get rid of it now
i've got about twenty thousand dollars
in savings um that i could either use to
dump into the car debt and try and get
rid of as fast as possible
um or do i try and keep building off of
that to get enough for a down payment
for the house cool i did that's a good
question it's a valid question how old
are you
i am 29 okay and you're fairly new to
this whole ramsey stuff right
um
i've been around it a lot but pretty
much ignored it most of my life but uh
that means you're new to it
i'm trying to get started now that's
okay that's okay it's all good and um
what do you make of your
i'm right around 105 000 a year good for
you and you're single
i am okay what do you owe on the car
uh right around 38 000. okay is that
your only debt
um
i kicked my student loans to the curb uh
last month they are gone now way to go
yeah the car's it the car is it all
right well there's two ways to go at
this okay
the fast way to get a house is dump the
car
and get your cheap get you a cheap car
and pay cash for it
the slow way to get a house is get the
car paid off and then save up your down
payment
i tell people and and there's a reason
for this i don't just it's not just
because
i don't want people here's the thing i
want you on a house i grew up in the
real estate business i love real estate
i think owning real estate's an
essential part of building wealth long
term so i do want you to get a house i
just don't want the house to get you and
when you have a 38 thousand dollar car
debt uh you don't need a house to get
that mess cleaned up okay because it's
gonna bite you in the butt
uh so i want you to have here's the
thing you move into a house with a car
debt and no money and you put all your
money down on the house as soon as you
do something's gonna break on the house
the roof's gonna leak
yep just murphy's law okay but if you
move into a house with no car debt and
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses and put your down payment
down and you got so you got money in the
bank no debt when you move in nothing
will happen to this house it'll be
perfect you'll love it
that's how life works man what kind of
car is it
uh it's a
the late model key it's a couple years
old
what could you get for it right now
probably more than i paid for it
probably more than 38.
i could probably get around 45 according
to kelly blue book brother sell it
yesterday
do you love this car has it wormed its
way into your heart
um i do like it but i don't know if i
like it that much yeah so here's the
thing yeah i'd sell it what i just told
you was the best way the only way i
would tell you to buy a house and i do
want you to buy a house
is when you have no debt and have an
emergency fund plus your down payment
okay
so the two ways to get there are quickly
dump the car buy a seven thousand dollar
car for cash you have no debt build your
emergency fund then build your down
payment then buy you a house that's
gonna happen very quick you have a house
by christmas
or
pay this car off
keep it
build your emergency fund
build your down payment and you'll have
a house by
the next christmas
or the one after that either one's okay
there's nothing dumb here because the
car is not completely out of control
given your income it's getting close but
it's not completely out of control the
if you want to know what out of control
is don't own things with wheels and
motors all totaled up to be equal more
than half your annual income
and you're not there fair enough unless
you got other things with wheels or
motors that we don't know about sir but
if this is the only one you got it's
below half your annual income so it's
keeper it's okay but you need to get it
paid off for you by a house or the stars
have aligned and you can get rid of this
thing you can have seven thousand bucks
you can walk over to the lot and buy a
beater
and seven thousand
right a sustainable car yeah and man now
you're talking you're debt-free you got
20 grand in the bank you were well on
your way now you can buy george
campbell's honda for less than seven
thousand you could buy that for about a
dollar forty-five have you seen that
thing
he starts it with a rope out in the
parking lot dave oh bro
[Laughter]
i drive bad cars and that car makes me
go come on man
george is truly not a car guy i've been
giving him a hard time on the air about
his car so yeah you can go either way
adam uh personally i like cars i'm a car
guy
uh but i like houses more
because they go up in value uh and until
recently cars have never gone up in
value and they won't long term but
recently they have been uh so i i
personally would dump the stupid thing
while the getting is good and get me a
house
and then move up in car with cash later
after i get my house
but it's not a big deal either way
you're not in the dumb column either
direction
i compared that with what you and i have
done before
you're nowhere near us adam yeah yeah
you you got us both of us beat i mean
and you're a lot smarter than we were so
all right nathan's in birmingham hey
nathan what's up
hey dave uh quick question for you about
long-term disability uh i just switched
jobs got a new job and uh looking at uh
purchasing it uh question is do i go
through my employer or do i go kind of
the the personal route
uh and get my own long-term disability
and keep it with me
uh you know if i were to switch jobs in
the future etc yeah you can go you can
get it most anywhere i i would get it
through your employer just because
you're going to find it to be about
probably 25 probably 75 cheaper
than in the open market a group policy
on on long-term disability is just it's
one of the best buys out there it's very
inexpensive
i'll tell you how inexpensive it is it's
the only kind of insurance at ramsey
that i pay a hundred percent of as the
employer
we furnish it as a benefit it just
doesn't cost me much to give it to
everybody
nothing like health insurance for sure
and so um
you know we pay almost all the health
insurance but not all of it we want
everybody have a little skin the game on
that but this stuff just doesn't cost
much but if you go buy it as an
individual policy i bet you're going to
find it's 4x
okay
i maybe it may be 3x but i mean
somewhere in there it's a lot more so
buy through your employer and here's the
other thing if you will buy it with
after tax dollars
after your check has gotten the taxes
out of it not before tax dollars
that's what i would do
because then if you become disabled your
disability income is not taxable oh
that's a good one i didn't know that if
you buy it with pre-tax dollars your
disability income is taxable
and uh it's a big difference big
difference i had no idea they would tax
your
disability benefits man they will take
it all
they tax everything man
tax everything so uh yeah it
yeah but still especially if you're in
uh this cost uh issue will be better
especially if you're in some kind of an
industry where
um
you you you know you're not just driving
if you're driving if you're just driving
a desk that's you know it's just
white-collared
cat the category of work you do dictates
the cost of long-term disability more
than your age or health what about those
little 12 a month dollar month to buy
the three three months oh that's awful
is it bad awful yeah stay away from this
stuff yeah that's just gimmick stuff you
need an emergency fund to cover that
jump
so that's all you need cover that you
have self-insured through that it's the
long-term disability that's a problem
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage debbie austin kate and
allison are with us hey guys how are you
we're great dave welcome where do you
live we live in northwest indiana just
um outside of chicago illinois okay cool
welcome to nashville thank you all the
way here to do a debt-free screen yes
very fun how much did you pay off 168
000
in 12 years
but our
journey actually started on n09 or
actually no 07
when we paid off 40 000 in two years
and that was credit cards um student
loans all the stupid things that my
husband and i did
so
when you put the two together that's
our total okay all right and yeah okay i
got you and your house range of
household income i don't know through
the 12 years maybe yes uh we started at
100 and um just doubled okay all right
what do you do for a living
i work at a church um i'm a children's
ministry director
very good and what was the 168 000
um the mortgage
oh look at the she's rolling out the
spreadsheet
[Music]
covered the whole refrigerator yes it
did wow i love it
that is a spreadsheet of all
spreadsheets so that's the 12 years of
marking it out yeah okay so 09 you guys
run into us i guess you know seven we
ran into you and then two years later we
were paid for the house at the house and
then 12 years more the house is paid off
correct very good what's the house worth
um
i believe the house is worth 350
000 now cool cool and how much you have
in investments
um
well my husband recently passed away oh
my god
um five months ago oh my so that's the
part of the story then a big part this
is a big part of our story okay well
tell me the whole thing let me back up
yeah i'll let you start you tell the
story okay
um so
ryan my husband uh loved to spend money
and so
his mentality was just to charge it and
so
when we found u107 he was a deacon at
our church
and they asked him they asked him to
find something um to get us to help
people in our church to do our finances
and he came across your program and he
listened to it in two days and he came
home and he said honey we're cr we're
cutting up our credit cards and we're
going to get out of debt and you're like
who are you and what have you done with
my husband i was
because it was something that i always
wanted
but um just wasn't able to get
both of us on board at the same time
so we went through it we he delivered
pizzas i watched 10 kids in my home
um the kids picked up cans in the
ditches like everything we paid to show
towards that forty thousand dollars went
off um to the forty thousand dollars
so then after that um we kind of slowed
our lives down because we were we had
three kids and we were really busy and
during that time ryan found the job that
he was currently at milwaukee valve and
so he was working more and had a goal in
mind and wanted to get to that goal and
so we kind of slowed things down
and so then over the over the 12 years
we
put
we
colored off our lines as much as we
could we did cash flow christian
education my kids went to christian
school
austin just will be graduating in may uh
with a degree in business and cash
flowed his um first or for his four
years of college allison or allison's in
high school and kate is a freshman at
florida gulf coast university studying
marine science
so um with all of that uh we cash flowed
three hundred thousand dollars in
tuition wow so um so what happened what
kind of illness did he have um he had a
blood clot to the heart
so no warning no it was a complete and
utter shock he
passed on september 22nd oh my gosh and
how old was he 46. oh lord yes oh my
gosh so i am
my family and i are
i would be in a completely different
situation today had dave ramsey not
crossed my husband's path
15 years ago because i know that i would
not be financially secure where i am
today i know i would be selling my home
i'd be getting a full-time job wow and i
don't yeah because
he had had everything in place and i am
completely taken care of what a good man
he was the best oh my gosh so um
yeah god is good he is providing for us
he has
been amazing um i just can't speak
enough about our lord yeah
and uh but the suddenness of this
tragedy it's that that's what gets you
yes i mean it always gets you but the
suddenness of this and as young as he
was
amazing and he was a great dad and great
husband to boot oh my gosh
his dream was to come here when we saw
um paid off the house and so
we're
that uh picture i just saw in the corner
over there that is a car that is a truck
i drove um it was a 2002 uh yukon excel
and uh she sees the
[Laughter]
the real heartache in that photo is that
truck right
he always uh said honey that truck's
gonna make us rich one day
oh that's a good line hey just just so
you know debbie he's here with you yes
he's here he is he's here with all of us
absolutely it's awesome yeah and
austin's got the headset on the second
headset so austin you were in college
when all this was going on right yeah so
he was sick for about two weeks
and uh
i mean me and him would talk on the
phone every day
for like 40 minutes every day and uh for
two weeks he just wouldn't pick up his
phone
and it was pretty hard but then
the day before he passed he felt better
and we talked on the phone
and
i was like
starting to apply for jobs and stuff
like that and he just said he was proud
and then
um
the next day he was gone those are the
three most important words the father
can say to his son as i'm proud of you
i'm so glad you got to hear that man
what a gift
he said that to his kids a lot oh gosh
what a great man
a great man it looks to me like he had
good reason to be proud absolutely yeah
absolutely you guys are studs you're
amazing yeah thank you very cool well
paying off the house and all that stuff
really doesn't matter
in the light of all of this except
that it gives you a a a comfortable
uh
safe place to grieve this extreme loss
uh i mean god if you had payments and
stuff coming out your ears and
everything else would be a whole
different world for you yes and so it's
a horrible thing that you guys have gone
through but um but the best of the best
possible way to go through a horrible
thing
you know i guess is the only way i know
how to say it there's nothing cooler
than you know people say the words i
love you a lot i'm proud of you a lot
and right now y'all are living
what love looks like what love
love with feet and hands on it right
which is a plan um that he worked that
in the middle of the night probably i
was sleeping to make sure that things
look at this spreadsheet
yeah there's that one that's
unbelievable
that just beautiful man i love this guy
was in the office next to he had it on
the wall get up leave the cave kill
something drag it home
with the mortgage principal right next
to it i love this guy he was a huge huge
dave ramsey fan he was a huge fan of his
uh your podcast every day
um it didn't matter
where we were um it was always on
what a legacy
talk about change your family tree man
yes he did wow yes he did thank you guys
for coming to share and it's a painful
thing for you to have to share
um but uh what a wonderful way to honor
the work your whole family has done but
certainly the
the leadership that he brought to your
family on this subject is pretty
incredible and set you guys up to win so
thank you for sharing that
oh i think my allergies are acting up
john yeah
there's dust in here man there's dust in
here i'm not crying you're crying that's
true that's right
oh you guys are awesome thank you so
much you're we're so proud of you thank
you very well done well we've got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you uh if
you're not already you will be you've
got the uh the table set and uh the next
chapter uh it wasn't the way you wrote
the book wasn't the way you were gonna
write it but uh the next chapter is here
and uh you guys are all set up to
go on and and move to what god's got for
you next yeah pretty incredible count it
down let's hear a great debt free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
unbelievable
wow
[Music]
oh
man
[Applause]
wow
this is the ramsay shot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 145 18 the
lord is near to all who call on him to
all who call on him in truth winston
churchill said truth is in contro
incontrovertible
panic may resent it ignorance may deride
it malice may distort it but there it is
i have never heard that quote from him i
haven't either i love it fabulous i love
it fabulous quote
all right we went out and i gotta take a
minute after that met with debbie and
the kids after during the commercial
break almost didn't make it back in
uh because the hugs and oh my gosh
what a um
poignant thing
oh my gosh
how often i've heard that question asked
um when somebody actually sets
everything up to take care of their
their family i i hear that question with
some regularity over the years
it's almost as if they knew
yeah well we do know that's right i love
your answer so her in-laws asked her
because her husband had everything set
up the wills and everything was set up
uh so what happened her in-law said did
he know he was going to pass and we're
like yeah we all know we're going to
pass yes that's why we do this we can
choose a lovely family or not put our we
get our act together oh my goodness
gracious beautiful
so um what three incredible young young
men and women their kids their kids wow
what a great what a great
legacy all right alan is in chicago hey
alan welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
i got a career question for you work i'm
a driver trainer for a small mom-and-pop
bone trucking company
make about 93 000 a year i got an offer
at a bigger more corporate trucking
company
and
the new job would be about six dollars
more an hour but they're not guaranteed
overtime in the job event now i'm
guaranteed 20 to 25 some working months
translate all of that into annual income
what are you going to make at the new
place annually and what did you make at
the at the current place annually 93
annually at the current place the new
place
do not guarantee me over time there's
some available i know what do you think
you'll make
about 70.
why would you go down
well it'd be
15 hours less a week
so i'd have more home time i guess how
many hours are you working
65 now
okay will mom and papa let you mom and
pop operation let you adjust down
could uh yes probably would i like the
income though that's one thing i'd like
the income i don't mind the baby step
seven no kids anything that nature so
the hours aren't really bothering me i
guess the hours aren't bothering you
make more money why would you take less
hours and work less then
because i figured the bigger the bigger
company the corporate company would have
probably more um
uh future opportunities i guess
they have to be a lot because you're
taking a 30 pay cut
and there's something about there's
something about going from
a small organization where you're kind
of the big dog you're a leader
to man you will be a expendable number
at a big giant corporation
yeah that's kind of guess where i want
your guys advice on to that i think that
the new job obviously would have more an
hour but less hours they weren't
guaranteed
the overtime there yeah but you're going
to make less money
and you told me money was important to
you and ours didn't bother you
true true
why would you go make less money and
work for a big company if you're a
burned out father with a couple of young
kids and you're like man i'm working 90
hours a week i miss my family i got this
other off-ramp well then that's a
different discussion but
i wouldn't want you to describe yeah i'd
stay where you are man jennifer's in new
york city hi jennifer welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thank you what's up
so i was calling for some advice
my mom's cousin just passed a month ago
and they had
nothing planned no well
you know advanced directive
so
my brother and i
um are trying to teach this as a
learning experience and
i did print out
will how advanced directive and i'm
planning on
speaking to her
about it
and i just want to see where i should
any advice where to go from here she
also is a hoarder
and
i have my own family
and
my own
um i'm very busy so i'm just trying to
navigate so what is your question
what do you want what how can we help
you just
um just some advice of how to speak to
her about this next chapter of her life
and
what advice you'd have for speaking to
her about
what to do with all of her stuff and um
basically yeah
and can you please in terms of what to
do in terms of her getting a will done
yeah
yeah okay
trying to get her to put something on
paper or something concrete so we don't
have another nightmare yeah
well
that's the way i would approach it it's
mom it would be a gift to me
and to my brother
if you had a will even if you leave it
all to someone else i don't need the
money
but if you would just make it make it
easier to deal with upon your death what
you want done by having a will it would
be a gift to us
and if you want some help getting all
that done jennifer just go to
mamabearlegalforms.com
mamabearlegalforms.com
and you can get a downloadable will very
inexpensively and she can you can you
can help her for 30 minutes to an hour
she can get it all filled out and she'd
have a will um but yeah you know that
but then she has the right to
you know if you make it easy for her to
do by coaching her holding her hand and
getting her to sign it not but not
because she thinks you want her money or
you want her dead or something weird
like that but just because
you want her to you want to be able to
make sure her wishes are fulfilled and
you're asking her to give you the gift
of clarity and legal
yeah okay and yeah that sounds good it
sounds like your mom has struggled with
she's got does she have mental health
challenges she's a hoarder she's got
stuff going on in her mind okay yeah so
yeah
have some space in your in in reality
have some space in your heart that this
conversation may not go well
that she may accuse you of all kind of
things get mad at you and not want to
think about her own death or letting go
of her stuff
and
know that that's stuff that she's
struggling with that's not on you okay
the responsible thing is to have this
hard conversation with dignity and
respect
but if it doesn't go well it doesn't go
well you know what i mean and it's not
worth going to war with um a mom who's
not well
but it is worth having that conversation
you know you ask
and you hold
the subject lightly don't let your
relationship with her hinge on whether
she does this or not
okay
and maybe tell her that you hopefully
you are
um you and your home y'all are getting
your wills all taken care of and your
brother's getting his all taken care of
this is just hey the family learned a
hard lesson with your husband passing
and we're gonna make sure this doesn't
happen we've got it all set up and we'd
love to have this conversation with you
yeah that's that's a big deal
and the big thing is it's very hard for
any parent to take instruction
regardless of their age from their
children
yeah we call it the powdered butt
syndrome once someone has powdered your
butt they don't want your opinion on sex
or money
okay and so it's it's hard it doesn't
even even though she you may be you
might be an estate planning attorney
doesn't matter and uh
and she might have never graduated
kindergarten but it doesn't matter she's
still your mother and she still thinks
she knows better than you that's just
how parenting works
so this is not something she you're
gonna go tell her you need to that's not
how you do this no no no
here's how you can love and help me
please give me the gift of that use the
word gift
it would be a gift to me
just like if your husband had had all
this done it would have been a gift to
you and us we wouldn't have been working
through all this in the barrel of fish
hooks right now we would have instead
been um
you know we would have been just
grieving his passing and still we've got
to work through all these legal
challenges and ownership challenges
because he didn't have this done and so
it's reminding me i'm doing it for my
family brother's doing it for his family
and it would be a gift to us if you
would do it to help us with you even and
mom we don't want your money it's not
it's not about money money you do
whatever you want to do with your money
it's your money it's your money we're
not here to try to get your money it's
not that's not the agenda or your stuff
we want to honor your wishes the best we
can yeah we want to we want you to have
your will
upon your death
told to us and it's called a will
that's why they call it that
so um it is absolutely vital
john deloney good show thank you sir
good show to the folks in the booth
great work back there
i'm dave ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you